nagorno-karabakh may be small in size
but the disputed region is rich in
cultural and religious heritage
this hundred year old monuments however
have seen better days
hundreds of monuments and historical
sites in this region have been damaged
vandalized or destroyed during the 30
years of war
thousands of graveyards the historical
educational institutions
museums they're now unrecognizable the
first publication house which was
established in the 19th century is
ruined
the russian orthodox church hajjal akbar
mosque the church of albania
merdingli mosque and murali shrine from
the 13th century are also damaged
in the immediate aftermath of the
ceasefire that ended last year's war
between azerbaijan and armenia
cultural institutions and scholars
voiced concerns
they said hundreds of historical mosques
church
monasteries monuments and museums could
be at risk
armenia says between 1997 and 2006
azerbaijani forces damaged or destroyed
thousands of the historical sites
including medieval church and graveyards
in narc japan but azerbaijan says the
cultural damage on his side
became more apparent after its armed
forces recaptured territories
armenia had controlled since 1993
and that the scale of the destruction to
sites including mosques and libraries
is bigger than expected experts believe
cultural reconciliation is still
possible in nagorno-karabakh
despite the dismal record of the past
three decades both sides have
demonstrated awareness
and even admiration of heritage that
isn't their own
son the war does not kill only soldiers
and civilians but also historical
heritage
there's no insurance for this heritage
both muslim and
christian heritage of this region have
been vandalized
we have to be meticulously careful not
to further harm the historical cultural
sites a mutual respect is what we need
i believe both sides have learned a
lesson that this destructive
war should not be a never-ending circle
which destroys
our common history buried within these
buildings are centuries of shared
tradition
culture and history of a people who
today call themselves
by two different names although the guns
are mostly silent
azerbaijan and armenia are still a long
way from peace
and many people here hope that the
historical treasures of nagorno-karabakh
don't also become casualties of war let
alone cause for another
resource azerbaijan